ça vous dit est ce que vous avez
vraiment pensé à prendre un
orthophoniste franchement jamais jamais
parce que regarder sa série mère j'avais
toujours ce problème il peut stresser
alou théâtre je ne bafouille pas une
fois pendant une heure dans le sport est
alors alésien et servir une phrase
devant moi après j'ai dit on va voir
tout de suite le magnet nous de même
langue de bois on va tout de suite voir
le magnéto de mes meilleurs bafouille
dans le prime de la vérité ce soir c'est
pour vous on va voir tout de suite le un
extrait de mes meilleurs bafouille dans
tpm pc pour vous c'est le palais de la
vérité un truc avec les animatrices a
pas trop quoi faire je te disais que
c'était un autographe de johnny beaucoup
les gens me manquer c'est pas du tout
donc toujours les gens gardent et le
shaq est jolie avec peut-être des
chèques les gens mais samedi on écoutait
rtl en racontant café pékin express
[Rires]
ils font ça pour le faire revenir dans
le rouge justement pour lui dire allez
reprend reviens à mon truc parce que
pour eux ils veulent que tout soit la
fin d'un stage
[Applaudissements]